dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on alpha here in this
series we often talk about computer
animation and physical simulations and
these episodes are typically about one
or the other you see it is possible to
teach a simulated AI agent to lift
weights and jump really high using
physical simulations to make sure that
the movements and forces are accurate
the simulation side is always looking
for correctness however let's not forget
that things also have to look good
animation studios are paying a fortune
to record motion capture data from real
humans and sometimes even dogs to make
sure that these movements are visually
appealing so is it possible to create
something that reacts to our commands
with the controller looks good and also
adheres to physics well have a look this
work was developed at Ubisoft LaForge it
responds to our input via the controller
and the output animations are fluid and
natural since it relies on a technique
called deep reinforcement learning it
requires training you see that early on
the blue agent is trying to imitate the
white character and it is not doing well
at all it basically looks like me when
going to bed after reading papers all
night the white agents movement is not
physically simulated and was built using
a motion database with only ten minutes
of animation data this is the one that
is in the looks good category or it
would look really good if it wasn't
pacing around like a drunkard so the
question naturally arises who in their
right minds would control a character
like this well of course no one this
sequence was generated by an artificial
worst-case player which is a nightmare
situation for any AI to reproduce early
on it indeed is a nightmare
however after 30 hours of training the
blue agent learned to reproduce the
motion of the white character while
being physically simulated
so what is the advantage of that well
for instance it can interact with the
scene better and is robust against
perturbations this means that it can
rapidly recover from undesirable
position
this can be validated via something that
the paper caused impact testing are you
thinking what I am thinking I hope so
because I am thinking about throwing
blocks at this virtual agent one of our
favorite pastimes our two minute papers
and it will be able to handle them
whoops well most of them anyway it also
reacts to a change in direction much
quicker than previous agents if all that
was not amazing enough the whole control
system is very light and takes only a
few microseconds most of which is spent
by not even the control part but the
physics simulation so with the power of
computer graphics and machine learning
research animation and physics can now
be combined beautifully it does not
limit controller responsiveness looks
very realistic and it is very likely
that we'll see this technique in action
in future Ubisoft games outstanding this
video was supported by you on patreon if
you wish to watch these videos in early
access or get your name immortalized in
the video description make sure to go to
patreon.com/scishow to driving the early
access program here on youtube just go
ahead and click the join button or use
the link in the description thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time